Tình hình anh anh bắt đầu 1 tại Ivan như khu sa đa liên biết được ra các biển phát,
nhiều nướng mức kính báo xú lịch,
kêu hỏi công dân xưa tảm và đón cờ cơ quan đại dịnh ngoại giao tại Tây Ranh.
Ngày bị sau thăm một, buông hoại rất nhiều bản thân báo đánh năng kính báo xú lịch
đối với Ivan lên mức độ bốn là mức cảm nhất.
Đồng thời hối thuộc bản bộ công dân như bản đã hởi đứng nạn những trong xưa tảm.
Chuy đó, những bản đã quyền nghĩ công dân không đến nhiều địa phương của Ivan.
Cũng trong ngày bị sau thăm một, Ní Zilun và Zilun và Kia thông báo đã tạm thư đón cờ cơ quan đại dịnh ngoại giao tại Tây Ranh,
và sớt tảm tạm bộ nhân viên ngoại giao.
Bộ ngoại giao điên xưa lên trở biến, khách nhà ngoại giao đã dựa yên át quan trên các chuyên bài thương mại
và họ đồng của đại xu quán nước chuyển xác phần phòng tại A'rha thu nghĩ kì.
Với phía Zilun và Kia, ngoại trứng đứng này, Jura Blaner, sắc nhận,
khu đình xưa tảnh đưa ra zong tình hình án đình bất đồn.
Đồng thời khẳng định quan bộ Yvm Vyên ngoại giao xưa và Kia hiện đã ăn quan.
Ní Zilun cũng khuyến cao công dân không xuất lịch đến Ivan,
đồng thời kêu khỏi công dân đang có mặt tại đây,
nhénh trong sự đi và kìm báo hả đầm bố trở lãnh sự hiện ở mất cờ kì hàng trế.
Ní Zilun cũng khuỏi công dân đang có mặt tại Ivan,
chủ đặc biến hệ với thân nhân để thông báo tình trạm.